ce monsieur le ministre voici presque
deux ans vous avez pris les rênes de ce
ministère sous une forme ou sous une
autre et les choix du gouvernement ont
désormais des conséquences sur la marche
du pays
force est de constater que la relance du
logement a été l'une de vos premières
préoccupations
malheureusement ce fut aussi la cible
des foudres de bercy la construction du
logement connaît aujourd'hui un sérieux
ralentissement les chiffres 2018 sont
inquiétants le nombre de mises en
chantier a baissé de 18% en 2018
coup de frein qui s'est amplifié en fin
d'année plus grave le nombre de permis
de construire délivrés ce qui fait
l'avenir baisse en 2018 et le recul au
quatrième trimestre s'est accentuée
enfin peut-être encore plus inquiétant
le taux d'annulation des logements
collectifs autorisés ont atteint en fin
d'année 27,3 pour cent le gouvernement
voulait être jugé sur ses résultats
nous y sommes exclusion de certaines
zones du dispositif pinel la fin de
l'acccident de la paix à l'accession la
limitation du prêt à taux zéro la coupe
dans les ressources des bailleurs
sociaux
toutes ces décisions purement budgétaire
auront produit leurs effets
malheureusement sur tous ces bancs lors
de l'examen des plf en 2018 en 2019 ou
de la loi élan les sénateurs vous avait
alerté sur les conséquences président
prévisible de vos choix
philippe dallier dominique estrosi entre
autres ne regrettez vous pas monsieur le
ministre
quand vous voyez les chiffres de ce
bilan de ne pas avoir écouté le sénat en
projet de loi de finances
comme vous l'avez mieux fait en loi élan
pour la parole et au ministère la ville
et du logement monsieur de normandie
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la présidente prima
vous l'avez vous avez raison vous l'avez
évoqué les chiffres de la construction
en 2018 sont moins bons que ceux de 2017
c'est à peu près un peu moins de 400
mille logements qui ont été commencées à
peu près quatre cent soixante mille
logements qui ont été autorisés
ça reste néanmoins vis-à-vis de l'année
2007 qui était une année exceptionnelle
ça reste néanmoins des chiffres qui sont
bien supérieurs à la moyenne des cinq
dernières années ce à peu près 25 mille
logements commencés de plus que sur la
moyenne des cinq dernières années
mais peu importe cela ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'aujourd'hui dans notre pays il
manque encore significativement des
logements songez qu'au moment où je vous
parle on construit à peu près autant de
logements qu'au début des années 80
alors qu'il y à 13 millions de
concitoyens en plus et une pression sur
les logements de plus en plus forte avec
notamment des divorces qui se sont
multipliés et alors qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire vis-à-vis de cela il ya trois
choses principales la première c'est de
mettre en oeuvre massivement et avec
beaucoup de rapidité la loi élan sur
laquelle vous êtes très impliqué madame
la présidente ainsi que madame la
rapporteur dominique estrosi sassone je
vous remercie d'ailleurs parce que vous
avez accepté de participer à ce comité
de suivi
il n'est dit que nous lançons dès mardi
prochain en votre présence
avec également vos collègues de
l'assemblée nationale deuxièmement il
faut lever les inquiétudes lever les
inquiétudes là où elle se trouve
notamment dans le logement social nous
étions hier avec votre collègue monsieur
le sénateur d'alliés pour la deuxième
réunion de la clause de revoyure et je
salue la présence et la participation
active de monsieur le sénateur d'allier
à ces travaux le troisième élément qu'il
nous faut faire c'est absolument pouvoir
poursuivre la réhabilitation également
des logements parce qu'il s'avère qu'il
ya la construction il faut la soutenir
par le truchement de la loi élan là où
elle est nécessaire mais il ya aussi la
réhabilitation ou les chiffres pour le
coup sont bien meilleures puisque cette
année si je ne prends que l'ana
uniquement l'activité de l'anah c'est
17% de plus de réhabilitation qui ont
été opérés et je crois que un certain
nombre de tragédies notamment le drame
de marseille nous ont rappelé au combien
cette réhabilitation était nécessaire et
que cette approche de logements que je
sais vous partagez madame la présidente
d'une approche différenciée en fonction
des territoires et peut-être ce qui a
manqué pendant un bouton et ce qu'ils
nous font aujourd'hui remettre en place
oui merci monsieur le ministre de cette
réponse mais vous savez très bien
monsieur le ministre je m'adresse aussi
au premier ministre danser danser dans
son budget que la sensibilité du
logement au budget aux décisions
budgétaires est extrêmement forte et
quand on a mis un coup de frein aussi
fort que celui qu'on a mis cette année
et bien pour redémarrer cette
construction ça sera extrêmement
compliqué et malgré la loi et en mal
la simplification qu'on est en train
d'opérer avec pacte tout ça n'aura pas
d'effet si on met pas un moment les
moyens pour le logement